und jetzt geht es um bezahlbares Wohnen
haben sie in letzter Zeit mal eine
Wohnung gesucht das ist eine richtig
richtig schwierige Sache und das ist das
Thema von Frau Schubert es ist ihre Zeit
es ist Ihre Kamera es ist ein Thema das
Ihnen am Herzen liegt bitteschön vielen
Dank vor etwa 14 Monaten haben etwa 60%
der Berliner Wählerinnen und Wähler sich
entschieden ein Volksentscheid auf den
Weg zu bringen den Senat auffordert
einen Weg zu finden die großen
profitorientierten Immobilienunternehmen
zu vergesellschaften also in
landeseigentümerschaft zu überführen
warum haben sie das getan weil sie
erstens erfahren haben dass spätestens
seit der Finanzkrise es vor allen Dingen
Immobilien Investoren Heuschrecken sind
die Wohnungen ankaufen Wohnungen wieder
verkaufen die Mieten hochtreiben zum
Teil sanieren um die Wohnungen hoch um
die Mieten hochzutreiben Mieterinnen und
Mieter zu vertreiben das ist sehr hier
in Berlin ein extrem großes Problem das
ist kaum noch möglich ist bezahlbare
Wohnungen zu finden weil bezahlbare
Wohnungen zu teuer geworden sind weil
sie Gegenstand von Spekulationen
geworden sind und das war glaube ich
dass die Hauptmotivation warum so viele
Berliner und Berliner für diesen
Volksentscheid gestimmt haben
deswegen ist es jetzt die Aufgabe des
rot-grün-roten Senats von dem ich hoffe
dass er dann auch am 12 Februar
bestätigt wird und seine Arbeit
weiterführen kann ein Gesetz zu
entwickeln dass es möglich macht diese
Überführung von etwa 300.000 Wohnungen
in der öffentliche Eigentümerschaft auch
zu organisieren und gesetzlich
abzusichern warum ist es so wichtig wir
haben in Berlin bereits jetzt etwa
330.000 öffentliche Wohnungen bei 1,8
Millionen Wohnungen insgesamt mit dieser
Vergesellschaftung würden wir den
Bestand öffentlicher Wohnungen auf dem
Schlacht mindestens verdoppeln damit
werden
ganz Deutschland ich muss einmal
einhalten
dass sie auch auf ganz Deutschland
sage wir probieren es jetzt mal aus und
versuchen das auch rechtliche
abzusichern weil
es ist Neuland es ist Neuland weil noch
nie wir haben zwar den Artikel 15 setzen
1949 im Grundgesetz stehen aber er ist
noch nie angewandt worden und wir müssen
jetzt sehen
kriegen das ist auch rechtswirksam ist
und warum ist es so wichtig wir müssen
die Mieterinnen und Mieter im Bestand
schützen damit sie nicht vertrieben
werden das wird wirklich das Argument
kommen da gibt's keine einzige neue
Wohnung das stimmt weil gleichzeitig
muss natürlich gebaut werden aber es
muss nicht irgendwas gebaut werden also
gerade für Berlin kann ich sagen wir
haben hier jede Menge teure Wohnungen
aber diejenigen die normale Gehälter
haben geringe Gehälter haben aber wenn
Sie mehr also
marktwirtschaftlich
also erstmal ist das eigentlich der
standkurs den man schon in den Schuhen
lernt aber spätestens sonst im Studium
wenn es irgendwo ein Mangel gibt oder
eine zu große Nachfrage da müsste man
das Angebot erhöhen das müssten wir in
der Energiepolitik machen das müssen wir
aber auch auf dem Wohnungsmarkt machen
was sie aber machen ist Sozialismus im
Grundstudium und wir haben wir haben
hier in der wir haben hier in Berlin und
äh ja im Osten Deutschlands eine lange
Zeit die DDR erlebt oder viele
Generationen haben die DDR erleben
müssen und da hat man gesehen dass all
das was sie jetzt hier eben auch
gepredigt haben überhaupt nicht
funktioniert hat ne die wohl
Wohnungslage in der DDR war doch keine
gute Idee da waren die Wohnung in einem
katastrophalen Zustand die Menschen
haben deutlich schlechter gewohnt als in
der Bundesrepublik
aufgewachsen und hat mit Sicherheit aber
auch eigentlich gar keine Rezepte der
DDR entschuldigen
ist in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
West in das Grundgesetz eigentlich
eingeführt worden
Angeboten falsch was sie sagen täglich
wird Artikel 15 angewandt zum Beispiel
dann lassen
jeden Tag in diesem Land und der
Bundeswehr irgendwo ein Grundstück
braucht geht der Bund hin und kauf das
raus das ist jeden Tag sozusagen
in der DDR groß geworden und ich habe
dort die Bruchbuden erlebt
Platz vielleicht einen Markt eine Mark
20 pro Quadratmeter bloß dann ist noch
1989 Klo eine Treppe tiefer
bruchbudenhaft die Häuser sahen
ausfahren durch die Bilder mal an wollen
sie uns das wieder bescheren genau das
eben nein doch nein
in dem ersten Satz haben sie gesagt
profitorientiert eine mein Gott
profitorientiert ist der Motor unserer
gesamten Wirtschaft ohne Antrieb ohne
ohne
Anreiz geht es kein Wettbewerb wenn es
kein Wettbewerb gibt kein Fortschritt
weil keiner was Neues ist Ideologie
nein nein nein nein wir gehen mal in
ihre Regierung
ist aber Ideologie
volkswirtschaftliche Logik was ich ihnen
beibringen will und das andere studiert
aber gut
Nachfolge ich will Ihnen
außerdem
[Gelächter]
sagen der Punkt ist doch ganz ganz
eindeutig sie müssen dazu sie sagen dann
übernehmen wir die Wohnung gibt's mehr
Punkt eins wenn nachdem sie
verfassungsviertel überwunden haben sie
sind schon mal auf die Schnauze gefallen
hier in Berlin mit dem mietendeckel
jetzt wissen Sie ja noch gar nicht
Verfassung müssen sie das zweite ist
darüber nehmen wir die Wohnung die
müssen erstmal bezahlen denn es wird den
eigenen in der Bundesrepublik in solchen
Fällen entschuldigen
sie werden ganze Kanzleien in den USA
damit beschäftigen ich will ihnen sagen
sie kommen mit diesem keinen Millimeter
weiter keine Wohnung mehr wird entstehen
es wird ein Zerfall eintreten Investoren
machen und die deutsche Hauptstadt ein
Bogen Berlin wird das blutprojekt des
Sozialismus und wenn sie das wollen mein
dies nicht gut mit dieser Stadt schauen
etwas dagegen sitzen ich würde gerne
dein hartmagazin
Geschichte es ist wie in der DDR das ist
so Platz
wie falsch unser Vorbild ist Wien das
ist jetzt nun nicht irgendwie Inbegriff
des Sozialismus da ist der Anteil der
kommunalen Wohnungen der kommunalen
Wohnungen aber deutlich wachsen höher na
ja wir hatten auch mal deutlich mehr
deutlich mehr landeseigene Wohnungen die
wurden leider verkauft das war auch mit
deinen Fehler meiner Partei damals unter
dem unter der unter der Bedingung dass
eben die Opposition vor
Verfassungsgericht gezogen ist um den
Haushalt anzugreifen und sozusagen der
Zwang war zu Haus als Konsolidierung das
Tafel Silber zu verkaufen und insofern
ist es sinnvoll um so so etwas wie
Steuerungsmöglichkeiten zu haben den
Anteil bezahlbaren Wohnung und der der
öffentlichen Wohnung zu erhöhen das hat
übrigens nichts mit Sozialismus zu tun
gucken sich die Wohnungen hier angucken
sich die Wohnungen der Dinge
dann gucken Sie sich dagegen an was in
den Wohnungen der deutschen wohnen oder
der vonovia los ist wo die Leute im
Schimmel wohnen wo die Sanierung nicht
stattfindet
sie wollen uns doch hier nicht einfach
erzählen
eigenen Unternehmen
gerettet aber ansonsten nicht
Kiste das ist das Problem
die hier wirklich
den Menschen immer realistisch das ist
doch das ist doch das ist doch überhaupt
keine Ahnung wie ein Programm
gesagt das ist das eine ist der Schutz
des Bestands das andere ist der Neubau
und der muss genauso organisiert werden
und zwar die ganze Sendung von
Verstaatlichung und sind gerade brauchen
wir sozialen Wohnungsbau ganz massiv und
auch da müssen unsere Landeshaupt
haben wir keine Übereinkunft ich habe
auch langsam hier auf der linken Seite
weil es wird sehr laut eine wirklich
können wir bitte einmal noch zum
Abschluss hier fliegen die mikrofutter
[Gelächter]
2015 nach Berlin gekommen
ich wollte ihn Mitbewohnern und dann
wusste ich die Mieten sind so wie sie
sind aber das war mir egal ich wollte
und dann habe ich aber durch das Dasein
mitbekommen was da abgeht und dann habe
ich aber auch mitbekommen wir reden
jetzt von vor acht Jahren
dass die ganze Diskussion ja schon
mindestens zehn Jahre existiert oder
noch länger und jetzt sagen Sie wir
wollen und wir müssen ja aber
seit ich in Berlin war waren sie in der
Regierung
genau auch ein aber Sie sind dabei